everyone has what love me to them crazy
season 2 of crazy ex-girlfriend
premiered last week and that means the
return of the hilarious musical numbers
one thing has changed a new theme song
change the theme song last season was
the lies we tell ourselves and this
season it's more about once you start
being honest with yourself what then
what what do you do with them on Friday
night's episode there's another catchy
song to look forward to and only we were
on the set I mean you must have so much
fun creating these musical numbers in
particular yeah my favorite part
so it's called ping-pong girl and it's
it's basically Rebecca's kind of fantasy
on what it would be like if Josh was
watching her play an awesome game can I
ask how many of your guys is like
real-life incidents make it into this
year we really also steal from friends
friends stories it's like a room of
tailor strips just writing stories and
songs about X's on and trying to figure
themselves out which i think is what Tay
Tay's just trying to do I think she's
just trying to survive you know
you